[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien guten Abend in Magdeburg
da sind sie völlig aus dem Häuschen das
und ein bisschen mehr später mit dem
Sport Katja zu Recht sind sie das
schönen guten Abend wir schauen
gemeinsam auf den Überblick
erste Schritte Richtung Entspannung
Chinas Präsident empfängt den
US-Außenminister um den festgefahrenen
Dialog zwischen Peking und Washington zu
verbessern
Fluchtroute Mittelmeer Innenministerin
Fräser sucht mit Tunesien Lösungen damit
weniger Bootsflüchtlinge die gefährliche
Reise nach Europa antreten
und eine Stadt steht sportlich Gott
Magdeburg ehrt seine Handballer nach dem
überraschenden Champions League
wenn die USA und China die wohl
mächtigsten Länder der Welt nach Jahren
angespannter Beziehungen aufeinander
zugehen und von Fortschritten sprechen
dann ist das für uns alle eine positive
Nachricht so geschehen beim Besuch von
US-Außenminister blinken in Peking er
wurde sogar von Staatschef Ski empfangen
über ein bisschen Zuversicht in extrem
komplizierten Zeiten berichtet Elisabeth
Schmidt
sie strecken beide die Hand aus und
gehen aufeinander zu es ist die Stunde
der besonderen Gesten Chinas Staatschefs
nahm sich eine halbe Stunde Zeit um
US-Außenminister blinken in der großen
Halle des Volkes in Peking zu empfangen
wir haben Fortschritte in den
Beziehungen erzielt und auch über
Einkunft in einigen Punkten das ist sehr
gut
die USA und China haben die
Verpflichtung ihre Beziehungen
verantwortungsvoll zu regeln das Treffen
Blinkens mit Chinas top-diplomaten Wang
i am Vormittag noch deutlich
unterkühlter wann sprach davon dass die
Beziehungen auf einem Tiefpunkt sein die
schulstufe allein in den USA zu eine
Stunde länger als geplant saßen die
beiden zusammen woran man übereinstimmte
man braucht sich vor allem auch
wirtschaftlich
ein Auseinanderdriften wäre ein Desaster
für uns wenn wir einen Handel mit China
einstellen würden wir wollen riesigen
minimieren und uns breiter aufstellen
die Zeichen stehen auf die Eskalation
und doch gibt es weitere streithemen den
Taiwan konfliktinas Freundschaft zu
Russland den gemeinsamen Handelsstreit
ich war ich hoffe dass sie durch ihren
Besucher Außenminister positiv zur
Stabilisierung unserer Beziehungen
beitragen werden
zumindest wolle man wieder
Kommunikationskanäle öffnen wieder mehr
miteinander reden Chinas Außenminister
werde auf Einladung Blinkens bald zu
einem gegen Besuch in die USA reisen
fragen wir noch mal nach in Peking bei
Elisabeth schmidt-elisabeth ist das
jetzt Tauwetter in den eigentlich
frostigen us-chinesischen Beziehungen
zumindest war das Gesprächsklima heute
deutlich milder es gab auch kleinere
Zugeständnisse mehr Visa für Studierende
und Geschäftsreisende das war auch ein
Anliegen Chinas vor allem mit Blick auch
auf die Wirtschaftskrise im eigenen Land
generell mehr miteinander sprechen das
hat sich die USA seit vielen Wochen und
Monaten gewünscht das war vor allem mit
Blick auf den taiwan-konflikt im Inno
Pazifik ist ja ein vergangenen Wochen
und Monaten immer wieder zu Scharmützeln
gekommen zu gefährlichen nahen
Begegnungen zwischen chinesischen und
amerikanischen Streitkräften was blinken
heute nicht gelungen ist das hat er auch
in der Pressekonferenz erwähnt ähm das
ist das die direkten militärischen
Kommunikationskanäle wieder aufgemacht
wurden aber dieses generelle bestehen
und zumindest dieses Eingeständnis dass
man jetzt weiter miteinander sprechen
möchte das ist schon ein Erfolg es ist
nicht der große Durchbruch hier in
Peking passiert aber die Eiszeit
zwischen den beiden Staaten die wurde
heute beendet live aus Peking Elisabeth
hab vielen Dank
auch in Berlin da gibt es gerade
Gespräche mit Politikern aus China
Ministerpräsident lician ist zu einem
mehrtägigen Besuch in der Hauptstadt zu
Stunde trifft er mit Bundeskanzler
Scholz zusammen zuvor wurde er von
Bundespräsident Steinmeier im Schloss
Bellevue empfangen beide Länder haben
schon angekündigt die Zusammenarbeit
beim Klima und Umweltschutz
intensivieren zu wollen in den kommenden
Tagen soll es unter anderem auch um die
Spannungen um Taiwan gehen
eines der größten Probleme für
Unternehmen in Deutschland ist der
Fachkräftemangel hunderttausende fehlt
schon jetzt heute hat sich die Ampel auf
Details für ein neues Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz geeinigt noch diese
Woche soll es im Bundestag verabschiedet
werden ein neues Punktesystem der
vereinfachte Familiennachzug sowie die
leichtere Anerkennung von Abschlüssen
sollen 60.000 zusätzliche Fachkräfte pro
Jahr ins Land locken beim heutigen Tag
der Industrie wird das auf Wohlwollen
gestoßen sein die vielen 100.000
unbesetzten Stellen sind nämlich ein
riesen Problem hohe Strompreise ein
anderes sie bremsen das Wachstum in den
energieintensiven Sparten von der
Aluminium bis zur Zementproduktion darum
spielen immer mehr Betriebe auch mit dem
Gedanken ins Ausland zu gehen es gab
also viel zu besprechen beim
Branchentreffen heute wie Frank Buchwald
berichtet
mehr als 600 Grad Hitze flüssiges
aluminiumrohstoff für Autoteile und
Verpackungen jede zweite Getränkedose in
Europa kommt bisher von hier aus Neuss
Norf nun aber soll Schluss sein Anfang
des Jahres hat das Unternehmen
entschieden die primärerzeugung hier am
Standort gänzlich einzustellen wir
werden uns zu einem großen Recycler
wandeln
bevor das also aber passiert gehen wir
jetzt erstmal durch den Teil der Tränen
und bauen und und wo 300 Arbeitsplätze
jetzt noch mal ab Strom in Deutschland
viel zu teuer ein Problem nicht nur für
die Aluminiumhersteller in Neuss die
hohen Energiepreise machen vielen
Unternehmen große Sorgen und der
BDI-Präsident appelliert dann die
Politik Rezession Investitions
Zurückhaltung Rückzug sind inzwischen
dauernd Themen das muss uns umtreiben
denn wir wollen doch beides dass die
deutsche Industrie in der Welt
erfolgreich ist und das System
Industriestandort Deutschland der
Standort gerade jedoch in Gefahr und
viele
Arbeitsplätze das weiß auch der Kanzler
beim Tag der Industrie aber hält Scholz
sich bedeckt
Priorität hat dass wir klimaneutral
werden und ein starkes Industrieland
bleiben
deshalb investieren wir in den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien in neue
Technologien in umweltfreundliche
Mobilität und klimafreundliche Gebäude
einem subventionierten
industriestrompreis erteilt der
Finanzminister zwar eine Absage aber wer
etwas tun will beim Strompreis der da
habe ich eine Alternative schaffen wir
Prioritäten im Bundeshaushalt und Senken
für alle die Belastung durch die
Stromsteuer da haben wir entsprechende
Verzerrungen nicht ich wäre dazu bereit
auf die Politik wollten sie ihr neues
jedoch nicht warten und setzen künftig
vor allem auf Aluminium Recycling
aus der Industrie sind sie nicht mehr
wegzudenken sie stecken in Autos tostern
Handys sowieso und werden immer
wichtiger Mikrochips um unabhängiger von
globalen Lieferketten zu werden will die
Bundesregierung in Magdeburg die
Ansiedlung einer chip-fabrik mit fast 10
Milliarden Euro fördern eine
entsprechende Vereinbarung mit dem
US-Hersteller Intel wurde am Nachmittag
unterschrieben mehrere tausend
Arbeitsplätze könnten dort entstehen
über die schwierigen Verhandlungen und
Hoffnungen Andreas Weise
noch ist es ein Acker am südwestlichen
Stadtrand von Magdeburg doch bald soll
hier eine der modernsten chip-fabriken
der Welt stehen hinter dem singer heute
zu Besuch im Kanzleramt hochzufrieden
ich habe zum Kanzler gesagt dass ich
mich darauf freue endlich mit ihm den
Spatenstich zu setzen damit es Ende
dieses Jahres Anfang nächsten Jahres
losgehen kann
ursprünglich wollte Intel 17 Milliarden
in den Magdeburger bördeboden stecken
knapp 7 Milliarden davon Subventionen
durch Ukraine Krieg Inflationen neue
Technologien seine Bedarf auf insgesamt
30 Milliarden gestiegen so Intel von
Finanzminister Lindner gibt es nicht
mehr stattdessen springt Wirtschaft und
klimaminister habe kein wir wissen dass
Digitalisierung die auf der einen Seite
neben Investitionen auch hohe
Energieverbräuche mit sich bringt und
jeder technologische Weiterentwicklung
die da einsparen hilft ist ein Benefit
für die
Klimaentwicklung und für den Klimaschutz
und deswegen ist auch die Differenz zur
großen Teilen aus dem klimafon gekommen
Milliarden Subventionen für viele
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler eine
zwiespältige Sache insofern ordnet es
sich auch einen politikstrategie in
europäische Strategie in dem Bereich der
Produktion Halbleiter mehr in
Deutschland zu haben aber
subventionsköpfe sind nicht nach oben
offen und man kann nicht beliebig
nachverhandeln und ich finde es auch
schwierig wenn Unternehmen den Eindruck
erwecken dass sie einen
subventionswettbewerb in Gang setzen
jetzt muss noch die EU-Kommission in
Brüssel zustimmen dann kann es für ihn
Teil in Magdeburg losgehen
Menschen die illegal nach Europa kommen
bei kaum einem anderen Thema Ringen
Politiker derzeit mehr umlösungen auch
heute wieder in den Ministerinnen Feser
ist nach Tunesien gereist denn von dort
machen sich inzwischen die meisten
afrikanischen Migranten auf den Weg über
das Mittelmeer rund
26.000 haben es von Januar bis Mai
riskiert mehr als 6 Mal so viel wie in
der gleichen Zeit im vergangenen Jahr
das Ziel der Innenministerin jetzt
Tunesien unter anderem beim Kampf gegen
Schlepper zu unterstützen Klaus Brodbeck
berichtet
Beitrag und bei Nacht greift Tunesiens
Küstenwache Boote voller Menschen auf
dem Weg nach Europa auf angezogen vom
hiesigen Wohlstand
es sind in dieser Zeit mehr und mehr
geworden im Vergleich zu den vergangenen
Jahren hat die Zahl deutlich zugenommen
europäische Politiker wollen das ändern
gemeinsam mit dem französischen
Innenminister sprach Nancy fazer heute
in Tunis über legale Zuwanderung für
Fachkräfte und Abschottung gegen andere
das geht darum dass furchtbare sterben
im Mittelmeer zu beenden es geht um
Menschenrechtsstandards es geht darum
auch
legale Wege zu schaffen damit Menschen
in Europa
einwandern können aber nicht sich auf
gefährliche Wege begeben müssen und
dabei spielt eine ganz wesentliche Rolle
auch die gemeinsame Bekämpfung von
Schlepper und schleuserkriminalität die
in aller drei Länder Interessen liegt
Unterstützung soll von allem dazu dienen
tunesische Polizei und Grenzschutz
Truppen zu verstärken um den illegalen
Flüchtlingen Einheit zu bieten und ihre
Rückkehr zu erleichtern Tunesien selbst
ist das erste Opfer der ungeregelten
Migration deswegen möchten wir unsere
Solidarität zu Ausdruck bringen
den werben begegnete Tunesiens zunehmen
autoritäre Regierung kühl schon früher
hatte der Präsident betont man sie sich
nicht als Wächter für andere der
Innenminister äußerte sich nach dem
Gesprächen heute nicht tun ist spielt
auf Zeit mit jedem neuen Boot steigt der
Druck auf Europa
3000 Kilometer südöstlich von Tunesien
liegt der Sudan ein Land aus dem immer
mehr Menschen fliehen denn dort toben
seit April Kämpfe zwischen der Armee und
medizionieren bei Angriffen wurden
bislang mehr als 2.000 Menschen getötet
25 Millionen die Hälfte der Bevölkerung
brauchen laut un-hilfe weswegen es heute
auch eine Geberkonferenz gibt und mehr
als 2 Millionen Menschen sind auf der
Flucht ein Ziel der Chart obwohl der
selbst Battle arm ist aus dem
flüchtlingscampfer China Susan von
Lojewski
das Essen kommt auf zwei Rädern und vier
Beinen auf dem Boden warten schon die
sauber geputzten Schalen Mittagessen
Zeit im Kämpfer Chana im Chat seit
Ausbruch des Krieges im Sudan sind
zigtausende hierher gekommen um sich in
Sicherheit zu bringen vor allem sind es
Frauen und Kinder
Mariam ischak wurde von Paramilitärs in
ihrem Haus überfallen ihr Mann trug sie
zehn Tage über die Grenze in den Schatt
sie sind Kriminelle sie haben uns
einfach angegriffen wir sind unschuldig
warum töten Sie uns wir haben gehört
dass die die da geblieben sind alle
ermordet wurden und wir können nicht
zurück in allen Verfahren hat die
un-unterkünfte für die geflüchteten
aufgebaut in der prallen Sonne warten
die Menschen dass der Tag vergeht wer
auf einem Esel kam hatte schon Glück
viele konnten gar nichts auf die Flucht
mitnehmen allein diese Region im Chat
hat über 150.000 flüchten da aufgenommen
mehr als doppelt so viel wie sie
Einwohner hat der Chat gehört ohnehin zu
den ärmsten Ländern der Welt und das
jetzt ist eine enorme Kraftanstrengung
mit dem Nötigsten sind die geflüchteten
vorerst versorgt doch der Krieg im Sudan
wird weiter andauern
Hilfsorganisationen fürchten dass die
Menschen vergessen werden
weiteren Zustrom von Menschen in den
Stadt unsere Kapazitäten sind erschöpft
wir brauchen mehr Mittel um ausreichend
Hilfe zu bieten
die Regenzeit im Chat hat bereits
begonnen dann kommt es vielerorts zu
Überschwemmungen und es wird immer
schwieriger den geflüchteten ausreichend
Schutz zu bieten
zur Stunde läuft noch die Sudan
geber-konferenz bislang gibt es Zusagen
für mehr als 1,4 Milliarden Euro
200 davon aus Deutschland
schwere stundenlange Gefechte heute in
Genin Invest jordanland zwischen der
israelischen Armee und militanten
Palästinensern mindestens fünf
Palästinenser werden getötet Dutzende
verletzt nach Angaben des israelischen
Militärs sind Soldaten bei einer
Festnahme unter heftigen Beschuss
geraten auch Sprengsätze wurden gezündet
israelische Kampfhubschrauber feuerten
daraufhin Raketen ab Gewalt im
israelisch palästinensischen Konflikt
hat seit Jahresbeginn deutlich
zugenommen
eine gewaltige Rauchsäule am späten
Nachmittag im Europapark Rust bei
Freiburg noch ist nicht klar was
passiert ist auf ersten Filmaufnahmen
sind auch Flammen zu sehen augenzeugen
berichten es habe mehrfach laut geknallt
die Polizei spricht von einem lokal
begrenzten Brand der von der Feuerwehr
bekämpft werde und unter Kontrolle sei
es sei nichts über verletzte Personen
bekannt die Besucher würden den Park
geordnet verlassen
der britisch-indische Schriftsteller
Salman rushdy erhält den diesjährigen
Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchhandels
die Verleihung findet Ende Oktober in
der Frankfurter Paulskirche statt der
76-Jährige seit trotz eines Lebens in
ständiger Gefahr einer der
leidenschaftlichsten Verfechter der
Freiheit des Denkens und der Sprache so
der Stiftungsrat im vergangenen Sommer
hatte ein Islamist Rusty bei einem
Attentat schwer verletzt er ist seitdem
auf einem Auge blind
so jetzt zum Fußball Katja das nächste
Testspiel steht an ja morgen Abend in
Gelsenkirchen spielt die
Nationalmannschaft der Männer gegen
Kolumbien und das Team hat es in sich
zuletzt sieben Spiele zweimal
Unentschieden 5 Siege es wird also ein
hartes Stück Arbeit für die DFB-Elf und
Hansi Flick vor dem letzten Länderspiel
der Saison zeigt der Bundestrainer
Verständnis für die zunehmende Kritik an
seiner Person die Ergebnisse geben wenig
Spielraum auf für was anderes her wir
wollen hier mit den besten auch
mithalten können dass immer im Moment
etwas weiter weg so weit weg das fliegt
darauf angesprochen den EM-Titel im
nächsten Jahr nicht als Ziel nennen will
neben Alex Schauer hält auch kein
Gündogan gegen Kolumbien in einer
Einsatzgarantie in seiner Geburt statt
Gelsenkirchen ich glaube dass ich jetzt
aufgrund der letzten Wochen wieder viel
positive Energie mit reinbringen kann
ich glaube auch eine gewisse Ruhe im
Stadion erhofft sich der DFB hingegen
lernen doch der Fan Rückhalt schwindet
noch sind mehrere tausend Tickets
verfügbar
mit 20.000 Fans komplett ausverkauft war
gestern in Köln das Handball Champions
League Finale zwischen dem SC Magdeburg
und kelze aus Polen am Ende oben
bekanntlich die Magdeburger den Pokal in
die Höhe und feierten heute beim
Empfangen in der Landeshauptstadt direkt
mal weiter
was die Fußballer nicht hinkriegen
schaffen die Handballer der Gewinn der
Champions League ist ein Meilenstein für
den SC Magdeburg den Pokal gab es
gestern schon in Köln nach dem Disney
Christian Zorn in der Verlängerung das
entscheidende 30 Tor zum knappen Sieg
geworfen hatte obwohl sich der Isländer
am Vortag im Halbfinale die Schulter
ausgekugelt hatte das Team hat nichts
ausgelassen
das ganze Wochenende in Köln war ein
Spiegelbild unserer Saison wir lagen oft
am Boden haben mit Verletzungen gekämpft
und die Jungs sind immer wieder
aufgestanden und haben mir Herz auf dem
Handballfeld gelassen
vor 21 Jahren waren die Magdeburger die
ersten deutschen Handball Champions
League Sieger jetzt sind sie fürs erste
auch die letzten
heute der nächste Wettkampftag bei den
Weltspielen der Menschen mit geistiger
Beeinträchtigung in Berlin und für die
deutsche Mannschaft gab es auch einige
Gründe für gute Laune
Annika Meißner sorgt für die erste
deutsche Medaille bei diesen Special
Olympics World Games bei spielwarmen
Temperaturen kämpft sich die 36-Jährige
in Berliner hans-braun-stadion als
zweite über 5000 m in 27,5 Minuten ins
Ziel persönliche Bestleistung
Erfolge auch bei den
freiwasserschwimmern klar dabei sein ist
alles aber für die meisten gibt es
nichts Größeres als eine Medaille in
Berlin zu gewinnen ich kann da jetzt
immer noch nicht so ganz glauben was
jetzt wirklich passiert ist das ein
Traum wahr geworden ist Leo Heckel hat
es geschafft im unified Wettbewerb
zusammen mit seinem nicht
beeinträchtigten Partner Adrian Schlüter
zusammen und Schlag war das Motto dieser
Special Olympics
[Applaus]
tolle Leistung tolle Menschen morgen
geht's weiter danke schön Katja von mir
gibt's noch eine kleine Klarstellung zur
Soda angeberkonferenz gibt Zusagen über
1,4 Milliarden Euro von Deutschland eine
Zusage über 200 Millionen Euro so schwül
warm und Gewitter ich geht es beim
Wetter weiter mehr dazu gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute journal das gibt's
um 21:45 Uhr mit Christian Sievers das
war's von uns von uns für Sie noch einen
schönen und entspannten Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt ist es vorbei mit der
trockenen Wärme und mit dem konstanten
Ostwind die Strömung hat gedreht auf
Südwest und das bedeutet schwülfeuchte
gewitterduft kommt zu uns und die
Gewitter kommen jetzt gerade in
Frankreich an und in der zweiten
Nachthälfte breiten sie sich weiter
Richtung Rhein und Main aus an der
Ostseeküste gibt es einige Regenschauer
sonst wird das noch eine ruhige Nacht
bei Temperaturen zwischen 20 und 14 Grad
für einige also eine tropische Nacht
eine Nacht in der die Temperaturen nicht
unter 20°c
und morgens schweißtreibende 27 bis 34
Grad und nur in den Küsten von Nord und
Ostsee ist es bei 24 25 Grad etwas
angenehmer morgen Vormittag gibt's noch
letzte Reste von schauen und Gewittern
der Nacht die fallen in sich zusammen
nachmittags kommt der neue kräftige
Gewitter von Westen heran das sind zum
Teil Unwetter Gewitter die mit Hagel
Platzregen und Strom verbunden sind und
auch am Mittwoch gibt es noch solche
Gewitter noch unwetterträchtiger wird
dann der donn Donnerstag bei
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 24 und 34
Grad zum Freitag beruhigt sich das
Wetter guten Abend